eigentlich nach häufigen film für alle
die zwei augen und zwei ohren hat
das ganze sollte ich vielleicht noch
dazu sagen ist in schwarzweiß
ich empfehle es wenn man nicht irgendwie
ein heimkino hat das eine große
dimension große bilder ermöglicht und
einen tollen sound her gibt würde ich
sagen ich denke es auf jeden fall für
den es sich lohnt ins kino zu gehen
der film heißt roma ist gedreht von
alfonso cuarón der in seinen filmen
bisher schon in der zukunft unterwegs
war in einer dystopischen zukunft die
mit schirmen und auch im weltraum
nämlich clarity das heißt wir sind von
ihm eigentlich filme in einer riesigen
dimension gewöhnt und dieses nun ist
eine familiengeschichte nämlich seine
familiengeschichte
es ist aber dass das autobiografische
angeht außerordentlich diskret oder und
privat insofern als er seine geschichte
eigentlich als geschichte ihres
kindermädchens erzählte cleo gespielt
von nizza paris und das ist eine
schauspielerin die eigentlich gar keine
schauspielerin dass sie zum ersten mal
vor der kamera steht und mit einer
intensität spielt da ist man eigentlich
die ganze zeit ihr über die schulter
kopf das erstaunlich an diesem film ist
nämlich dass sich das leben um das es
geht in roma übrigens das hört sich zwar
italienisch an ist aber in diesem fall
der name eines gutbürgerlichen viertels
in mexiko stadt ein viertel in dem die
häuser hinter hohen mauern verschwinden
und dadurch ein hof zustande kommt unter
freiem himmel der natürlich auch geputzt
werden muss weil der hund da immerhin
kommt und das ist ja ein ganzes passiert
eigentlich in so fern doch gar nix
verraten was bis jetzt passiert mich
eigentlich gar nicht viel außer dass ich
das leben dieser familie ausbreitet vor
uns und wir das bedeutet es ist eben
nicht erzählt wie eine story sondern es
entfaltet sich wie eine
das ist ganz wunderschöne und gibt dem
ganzen eine ganz eigene dynamik
es gibt originaltöne natürlich die auch
sehr sehr kunstvoll sind im autoradio
wir ein anderes radio natürlich die
stimmen untereinander es wird auch
gesungen und so aber es gibt nicht so
eine durchkomponierte filmmusik die uns
ja immer auch so ein bisschen erzielt
wie wir uns fühlen sollen wie wir uns
fühlen sollen sagt er uns überhaupt mich
in diesem sondern er entfaltet eben
diese diese kindheitserinnerungen die
gleichzeitig eine erinnerung ist an
mexiko in den 70er jahren und er ist
mexiko ziemlich im aufruhr und es gibt
das das dass das corpus christi massaker
ist ein großer zusammenstoß zwischen
demonstranten und polizei und auch das
kommt vor wird ein geworden und gefilmt
aus einem möbelhaus heraus und wie er
das macht zeigt eigentlich die ganze
kunstfertigkeit dieses regisseurs der in
der lage ist ganz kleine persönliche
intime empfindungen geschichte hat des
heranwachsens a zusammen zu bringen mit
den großen politischen ereignissen aus
der zeit in geld
[Musik]